okay so a fisherman from florida
recently got bitten by a lemon shark
and this is making news because a couple
years ago he was
also reported to of had been attacked by
an alligator while he was alligator
hunting paul lemon shark
not bad right uh yeah it'll still mess
you up really
like also not bad unless there's food in
the water he probably i'm guessing he
had some food with him he was
fishing or something but they're
generally pretty calm they're very
docile unless there's food in the water
and they're they're the sharks i had to
push away
when they threw the fish blood into the
water and so they can get now is that a
lemon there
no it looks like it i can't tell i'm
thinking oh i'm thinking of a leopard
no that's a um what they call either a
sand tiger or a ragged tooth shark
uh we call it um uh no shark in
australia they're
they're very docile very very yeah
because i've been in the water with them
and pushed them away
and um and i wasn't and i can't tell the
picture
oh look i put there i put the fish in
the hole right before i surfaced
wham yeah so he's he had fish in the
water yeah yeah see that's the thing
you're making yourself part of the food
chain at that point you've got the food
they want attached to your
you gotta you can't get upset when you
get yeah
i mean i feel like he survived an
alligator attack yes that's way worse
right
how big was the alligator another good
point but the alligator will
death row you right or is that the croc
i think both of them do it
did you see the alligator they saw in
queensland that monster alligator
catching crocodiles discovery channel
those things are way more terrifying
than sharks these things are freaking
dinosaurs
like 18 20 foot long bring up that one
hunt
aren't they perfect like like they have
they haven't really changed that
much 300 million years well have you
seen that
other thing they just discovered last
week scientists discovered
uh the the back in the day there were
alligators size of buses and they said
their teeth were the size of bananas and
they would attack
t-rex it's nuts i mean where's that one
in queensland
scientists are trying to bring these
creatures i know like jurassic park
yeah but please do not do that jason
you're the
jason alex everybody mike i won't talk
to you so that's that's why mike got me
here i don't even know
who you are how dare you how dare you
man i'm jason ellis though it's nice to
meet you i know i should
change phone numbers one day it'd be
awesome text me and i would [ __ ] show
up [ __ ]
i know dude well but yeah i i feel
you're busy i get it well you're busy
you peddle a lot i see that dude you're
busy are you really that thick
what is with this am i sick i don't know
that's my big
dude i'm getting on a road bike it's
helping right i think i mean
yeah i think so when it's all i do when
lockdown's over he's my project i'm
getting him shredded yeah i'm making him
[ __ ] bruce lee
to be lean in this pandemic you're the
opposite you're the rare right because
everyone's sort of getting fatter
everyone's put on weight do you i've
always said
my life was so much easier when i was
using drugs and drinking every day
my life's so much better now oh it's a
million times better
but
i had one thing on my mind i was like
where am i going to get
drugs where am i going to how how am i
going to start drinking
and then i achieved that and everything
was fine yeah and i didn't worry about
mortgage i didn't worry about being
respected by my child i didn't worry
about my wife and her
feelings i didn't worry about my
standing professionally yeah now
i everything is so so high i'm so
kind of high strung when it comes to
like remaining
above the standards that i set for
myself when you set no standards
it's really easy really but but it's
also it's not very fulfilling you know
it doesn't make you very happy you know
and i think that that's
on a large scale that's kind of the way
things are in any professional
field you when when you're just kind of
scratching the surface you don't really
hold yourself to that kind of standard
but then when you get to a point where
you have success
it's it's it's it can be miserable to
then
try to not only maintain it
professionally but also maintain your
sanity
within that world you know it's it's and
again it's not bitching about being
successful i'm simply saying
especially in entertainment and sports
because there's
no [ __ ] stability and having no
stability in your life as a grown man
with a family it's crazy
is really [ __ ] hard to wrap your head
around with you know it's it's a really
good
thing but then to add to that then you
toss in social media and there's a
million opinions
and there's this and there's that so i'm
like i'm out yeah well if you care
yeah people on there exactly every now
and then you go down a wormhole of
you're having a conversation where you
care and this person was just
trying to ruin your day yep and now
you've been booby trapped into hey man
but you see the the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you suck dicks and i'm
like ah
man i was waiting man i was trying to
help like
yeah i know i suck a dick
[Laughter]
yeah but but do you find though like i'm
sure you both have experience with it
for every one of the
yeah but you suck dick guy there's also
the the dude that you respond
you know even if it's a troll and you
respond you say something and the guy
goes
oh dude i didn't think you were going to
actually respond i'm sorry i didn't mean
that
that happened so much where i was like
well i'm sorry you feel that way i i
guess
i'll try to there's a lot of people that
go and yep you still suck dicks
yeah yeah just so you know yeah you go
thank you
i'm like oh man really just like this
give me your breaks like you [ __ ]
suck mad dicks
howard stern is on his last contract
right
yeah sure yeah i mean i don't think
those dudes leave i think they're just
larry king it
they just do like he'll do like three
days a week or two days a week they're
just gonna cut down everyone's all well
never gonna leave i'm like where's he
gonna go
they'll never shift him to me it's over
and i'm too roaring what do you what do
you mean
you mean there was a time where it was
like the future of siriusxm blah blah
but they got they're like dude
the whole i just talked way too much
about
you know like cern did this new thing
where he's got celebrities and he's a
little less raw and that's sort of what
mainstream wants from people and i'm
i've gone the opposite you know i mean
blown
grinder it's not yeah it's not like
mainstream like oh man let's get a bunch
of sponsors and they
are on that tip they want corporate
sponsors i get it i don't sell
yeah yeah they're like wait what did he
just say yeah theragun doesn't want to
know about
my saturday night [ __ ] big girls yeah
yeah yeah
because people love hearing about
[ __ ] people i know but they're yeah i
think howard is like how you were
describing muhammad ali
in his retirement he still was at fights
going no no i'll get in your camp and
then
like i think when it comes to
broadcasting and doing a radio show
the guy there's that fire has not gone
out
his interviews are good it's a different
show though for sure it's also listed
it's wildly different but it's i don't
think he's that i mean i think he lives
and breathes
doing quality radio and he could never
be stopped he would die
pulled away from him yeah i agree i
don't know what he would do like regis
like he might just leave for like the
last five years of his life and then
dies that match
he's pretty healthy yeah i think that
dude just like eats
little bits of salmon like he sounds
like he really takes care of himself
he's doing better his parents are still
alive yeah i know the dude's [ __ ] 70
and his parents are alive
what else she going to do dude and
they're lucid like his dad can't hear
very well but he's still
sharp right here he will be alive all
the shows
remember this chin i got out and i want
coffee and i thought i didn't know they
had different currency in
new zealand in australia so i just had
all this i just laughed at you yeah i
just had all this australian money i
went to new zealand to get a coffee and
she's like what are you doing
yeah yeah what are you doing
shoot they like tore into me oh my bad
and they got such a good sense of humor
yeah i was like my man everyone that
goes to australia i tell them
while you're there go see new zealand it
is one of the most beautiful oh my god
the most beautiful postcard beautiful
yes melbourne i will tell you though
i'll tell you the one thing i like about
it it had a very new york kind of energy
it's very cosmopolitan
but every time i said where's the best
so-and-so food
you know ultimately they always it
always ended with
and then go down the alley and in the
alley i'm like why are all your best
restaurants you know
everything's in the alley man everything
is because i guess because i was in
uh yeah you're like step over the
homeless dude
yeah sydney tried to copy it as well but
they're not doing as well
australia to me because i get you know i
was touring there so i was in the main
cities it just felt like uh
a cleaner america yeah it was just
everything exactly man unless you're
going to somewhere like prague
that has all these gothic castles and
all that it's like every city is the
same that's why you've got to get out of
the cities like you don't go to
australia to go to sydney yeah you go
and ride the ferry across the harbour
and see the bridge and the opera house
awesome then you go up to darwin then
you go see some crocodiles you go out to
western australia see some wildlife yeah
that's the australian people yeah
that's so when i i didn't like on the
menu they called uh
seafood bugs oh that's a specific that's
a specific sort of it's called the
balmain bug
yeah it's a specific sort of uh
crustacean yeah they're delicious
it's like uh it's like lobster yeah the
same kind of uh
consistency yeah east coast lobster or
i'm not familiar well because the the
rock lobster which is called out here is
a little tougher the main lobster is
that red
mm-hmm with a it's it's a it's
definitely succulent yeah this is
that's a little tougher yeah but well i
don't promote eating my friends
it's not like i was i wasn't doing it my
whole life
you know with mango sauce you know what
when i i remember when i texted you when
i was in australia and i was like what
should i do
and you sent me a whole list of stuff
i'm like i got three hours and you're
like yep
you're [ __ ] yeah